bonsoir
bonsoir Frédéric bienvenue parmi nous
plutôt vous appelez le numéro d'urgence
avec la voix d'un adolescent de 14 ans
et vous expliquer que vous êtes ce Léo
balai disparu en 1996 voilà vous
expliquez que vous venez d'échapper au
ravisseur une famille de pédophiles du
Nord de la France vous expliquez que
vous voulez retourner sur les lieux de
l'événement et arrivé sur place vous
appelez les gendarmes
vous dites avoir vu deux adolescents se
disputer au bord de la route et l'un
d'eux était Léo voilà un peu comment
vous comment vous fonctionnez
drôle de bonhomme quand même très bien
résumé oui pourquoi vous faites ça au
départ pourquoi qu'est-ce qui vous prend
pourquoi à un moment vous vous décidez
d'appeler en disant voilà je suis Léo
balai j'ai échappé mes ravisseurs et
vous emmener finalement les gendarmes
sur une fausse piste puisque bien
évidemment il y a plus rien sur les
lieux de l'enlèvement pourquoi au départ
qu'est-ce qui vous motive pour faire ça
Frédéric le besoin d'affection le besoin
d'amour le besoin d'exister le besoin de
ne pas être seul tous ces besoins là les
besoins qu'un être humain a besoin pour
survivre et c'est vrai que je me donne
tous les moyens qui sont mis à ma
disposition pour pouvoir le faire et je
ne recule devant rien
une autre solution c'est de faire
animateur télé
les gens vous aiment bien aussi
mais ça part du même sentiment
de gens qui nous détestent alors quand
les gendarmerie donc dans l'Isère à
l'endroit où a disparu ce Léo balai vous
dites je suis Léo c'est à dire que là
vous vous continuez l'imposture jusqu'au
bout vous dites je suis Léo et il faudra
un test ADN pour démontrer
définitivement que vous n'êtes pas Léo
parce que vous avez une capacité de
manipulation et de séduction aussi il
faut bien le dire absolument
extraordinaire quoi
je ne sais pas je pense que
les identités que j'ai pris et ce que je
suis devenu maintenant ça fait presque
un
capacité de séduction comme vous
l'appelez ou
la capacité de manipulation c'est avant
tout ce qu'on a fait de moi
il n'est nul mon attention de faire du
mal à qui que ce soit le plus important
pour moi c'est que l'on m'aime et c'est
tout je comprends très bien Frédéric mec
quand le monsieur balai le papa de Léo
balai en lui dis on a retrouvé votre
fils il a échappé assez ravisseur cette
famille pédophile du Nord de la France
il a un espoir même ça fait 8 ans qu'il
a pas vu son fils et à ce moment-là bon
lui dit bah non finalement c'était un
imposteur c'était Frédéric Bourdin vous
vous mettez à la place à ce moment-là du
papa de Léo balai quand la gendarmerie
m'a trouvée et qu'ils ont dans un
premier temps dit bon c'est du 55 ans
c'est peut-être Léo c'est peut-être
Paléo qu'ils m'ont ramené à la
gendarmerie
ils n'ont appelé personne la seule
personne qu'ils ont appelé c'est un
magistrat et il était hors de question
de prévenir la famille avant d'être
certain que j'étais Léo donc là vous
avez pas fait de mal à la famille balai
en tous les pianos en aucun cas donc
vous êtes mis en prison à l'issue de
cette affaire un expert est nommé qui
dit qu'effectivement dans votre
personnalité il y a des facteurs
manipulateurs séducteurs pervers enfin
c'est exactement le film de Spielberg
quoi vous êtes capable de prendre comme
ça des personnalités à l'envie parce que
quand vous faites les hauts balais vous
prenez une voix de 14 ans quoi alors que
vous avez beaucoup plus de 30 ans
la voix que je prends
je pense qu'elle fait un petit peu moins
de 14 ans mais c'est vrai que non
l'intention c'est de passer pour un
adolescent parce que je sais ce que je
peux faire et je sais ce que je ne peux
pas faire il faut pas non plus sombrer
dans le délire maintenant vis-à-vis de
la vie de l'expert
comme Christophe l'a dit dans son livre
Le déchiffreur d'âme
je crois qu'il est certainement plus
pervers que moi
vous en pensez quoi Christophe je pense
que objectivement c'est un peu compliqué
de prétendre
déchiffrer l'âme de quelqu'un
au cours d'un interrogatoire de deux
heures dans une pièce gardée par des
gendarmes
moi ce qui m'a lancé dans cette enquête
c'est d'abord la curiosité lorsque
effectivement j'ai pris connaissance de
cette affaire de de Grenoble la
curiosité d'abord et ensuite
c'est comme il est énigme à résoudre
parce que dans les premiers comptes
rendus de la presse tout est très
simplifié en gros on explique que cet
homme de 30 ans a voulu prendre la place
d'un enfant de 14 ans en réalité quand
on enquête qu'on creuse un peu on se
rend compte que c'est pas aussi simple
que
Frédéric Bourdin n'a jamais réellement
voulu prendre la place de cet enfant
parce qu'il est trop intelligent pour ça
il sait très bien qu'il va prendre il va
pas tromper les parents pourquoi vous
lui avez fait confiance à lui
d'abord j'avais besoin de faire
confiance à quelqu'un j'ai toujours eu
besoin de faire confiance à quelqu'un
parce qu'être seul c'est pas facile
surtout quand l'aide depuis longtemps
donc c'est vrai que j'ai toujours voulu
m'ouvrir aux autres et j'ai toujours
voulu m'expliquer j'ai toujours voulu
qu'on comprenne lui m'offrait la
possibilité je vous dis quand il m'a
parlé du livre la première fois j'ai pas
trop cru
ceci dit il m'a posé des questions
je lui ai répondu et dans la lettre qui
m'est parvenu ensuite dans sa nouvelle
réponse les recherches qu'il avait déjà
commencé à faire m'avait vraiment épaté
étant donné que c'était des détails que
même moi j'aurais pas réussi à retrouver
donc
juste un mec sérieux quoi non seulement
sérieux mais une très grande qualité
professionnelle en tous les cas pour le
moment Frédéric étant en liberté après
quatre mois de détention préventive
alors vous êtes en liberté sous contrôle
judiciaire jusqu'au procès qui aura lieu
fin 2005 dans quelques mois est-ce que
vous savez ce que ce que vous risquez
pour
je vais très certainement retourner en
prison si jamais je vais au procès
je pourrais même y retourner n'importe
quand en prison étant donné que je ne
respecte pas mon contrôle judiciaire de
façon volontaire et délibérée
parce que bon ça aide pas très peut-être
la foule mais je n'ai pas je n'ai pas un
travail je n'ai pas de syndicat on ne
paye pas pour venir pointer au
commissariat de Paris et l'étiquette de
train ça coûte cher et donc je ne peux
pas répondre aux obligations
de Grenoble et je ne me fatigue pas trop
non plus pour pouvoir
j'ai une vie à mener à côté de ça qui
est évidemment continué à me faire
placer dans des foyers
donc pour répondre à votre question oui
je le jour où les gendarmes attraperont
encore ça sera sans doute pour pour me
remettre en prison ça vous dérange pas
de retourner en prison
maximum que tu risques
mais si le procureur se débrouille assez
bien j'ai tout à fait confiance en lui
je suis sûr qu'il peut me donner trois
ans si il veut trois ans alors quand on
vous demande pourquoi vous faites tout
ça vous dites pour devenir célèbre et
quand on vous demande pourquoi vous
voulez devenir célèbre vous dites parce
que à ce moment là j'en profiterai pour
faire des choses bien vous ferez quoi
quand ça serait mon rêve dire si je
pouvais devenir comme Michael Jackson et
ben
j'investirais
vous avez pas un meilleur exemple
Frédéric non il faut dire il faut dire
monsieur que Thierry pardon que c'est
mon idole donc même malgré les
accusations de pédophilie qui sont
portées contre lui qui sont j'ai eu
aussi des suspicions vis-à-vis de
moi-même comme quoi j'étais pédophile
moi je sais qu'il n'est pas pédophile
je n'y crois pas
et quoi que quoi qu'on en dise je ne
changerai pas vis-à-vis de ça maintenant
pour faire des choses de bien j'ai
compris malheureusement que dans cette
société avant tout il faut de l'argent
il faut de l'appui
moi je ne suis pas du genre mendiant ou
demander quoi que ce soit à qui que ce
soit mais il est vrai que bon j'ai
certains talents et je rêve toujours
dans mon petit monde à moi qu'un jour
quelqu'un l'air marquera et que je
pourrais devenir quelqu'un de bien
quelqu'un de
chanson je suis un très bon danseur je
suis je sais parler je sais
qui savent parler on en charge il y en a
assez tout à fait ce que je veux dire
c'est que je sais m'exprimer je sais
défendre mes points de vue je je très
fort il a 139 de coin sur intellectuelle
et tout il a il a berné la terre entière
en attendant vous avez quand même passé
la moitié de votre vie d'adulte derrière
les barreaux
la moitié de ma vie adulte comme quoi le
temps passe vite mais vous me direz j'ai
pas raté beaucoup de matchs de foot donc
c'était c'était assez plaisant mais
ça vous dérange pas tant que ça
finalement
c'est un sacrifice à partir du moment où
moi je choisis
de façon volontaire en sachant
parfaitement ce que je fais de me faire
passer pour un mineur c'est à dire un
mentir à des officiers de police des
gendarmes à la loi afin de me faire
placer dans un foyer avec des gens qui
s'occupent de mineurs et avec des
mineurs ou dans des familles d'accueil
pour que l'on m'aime et qu'on s'occupe
de moi je me rends compte que je que je
ne respecte pas la loi
sur le sur le sur le bien sûr sur
comment ils appellent ça quoi outrage à
magistrat outrage agent de la force de
l'ordre et donc je suis condamné à de la
prison mais si c'est le prix pour être
un peu aimé et pour être dans un endroit
où on va même quelques temps si jamais
je dois faire de la prison pour ça et
ben je suis prêt à le faire toute ma vie
justement
c'est vrai qu'au départ vous avez pas eu
beaucoup de chance vous dites je déteste
ma famille et c'est vrai que vous avez
pas été beaucoup aimé il faut bien le
dire Frédéric Bourdin vous naissez en
1974 d'un père inconnu en fait un
ouvrier algérien mais ça vous la prenez
seulement quand vous avez 8 ans
se perd en fait était d'ailleurs déjà
marié il avait 3 enfants en Algérie et
vous naissez malgré l'opposition de
votre grand-père maternel qui suggère
fortement à votre mère de se faire
avorter vous tirez de ça cette espèce de
naissance par accident d'une certaine
façon parce que vous avez échappé à cet
avortement souhaité
vous en tirez un profond malaise
c'est toujours
ça m'a toujours manqué un père
ça m'aurait fait du bien d'avoir un père
ça m'aurait fait du bien d'avoir une
famille de cours
j'avais une grand-mère qui a fait du
mieux qu'elle pouvait la pauvre femme
mais
elle n'était pas dans une situation très
facile il y avait beaucoup de conflits
familiaux avec ma mère etc et
oui c'est vrai que c'était assez
compliqué
vous dites on m'a menti depuis que je
suis né
du plus longtemps lequel je me rappelle
j'ai toujours voulu savoir qui était mon
père donc évidemment la chose la plus
logique qui m'est passé par l'esprit
c'était de demander à ma mère
il y en a qui vous disait qu'il était
grand qu'il était élégant ma mère et il
y en a d'autres qui vous disent que
c'était un petit gars un peu minable
quoi vous avez jamais suivre vraiment je
me dis que c'était pour que je sois
assez optimiste un mélange des deux je
pourrais me contenter mais moi ça je
m'en serais foutu qu'il soit petit et
minable je mange je m'en foutrais qu'il
soit laid qu'il est 3 oreilles et quatre
pieds moi ça m'aurait intéressé d'avoir
un père quoi qu'il soit alors voilà vous
avez été séparé de votre mère à l'âge de
deux ans
quand vous dites que votre mère vous
frappait que c'est pour ça que vous avez
été séparé d'elle est-ce que vous dites
la vérité ou est-ce que vous mentez
Frédéric je ne dis pas que elle me
frappait c'est pour ça que j'ai été
séparée d'aller je dis qu'elle me
frappait oui maintenant ils m'ont séparé
d'elle parce que apparemment
elle s'occupait pas de moi moi je dis
que j'aurais préféré par moment qu'elle
s'occupe pas de moi ma mère
aimer frapper son bébé MF frappait son
enfance son petit garçon pour le plaisir
de pouvoir le réconforter une fois qu'il
pleurait
je lui en veux pas je l'aime parce que
c'est ma mère je la respecte je suis
désolé pour elle je ne pourrai jamais me
réconcilier avec elle non pas parce que
je ne veux pas mais parce que
elle est comme ça mais voilà c'est c'est
une personne qui a été malade toute sa
vie malade d'amour comme quoi ça oui
parce qu'après après votre père elle se
remet avec un autre homme et là c'est
pire que tout c'est à dire qu'il la BAT
enfin il termine en prison etc sur le
fait que sa mère battait Frédéric est-ce
que est-ce que vous confirmez vous moi
je ne peux pas le confirmer ce que je
sais et ça fait aussi partie de
Frédéric dit qu'il est né dans le
mensonge moi ce que je sais c'est qu'il
y a trois versions différentes il y a la
version de Frédéric la version de sa
mère et la version de son grand-père
puisque c'est le sol vivant de ces deux
grands-parents son grand-père dit qu'on
la retire à sa mère parce que sa mère
préférait sortir en boîte de nuit plutôt
que de s'occuper de son fils sa mère dit
qu'on lui a retiré son enfant parce que
ses parents ses propres parents
voulaient récupérer les allocations
familiales et Frédéric dit que on lui a
on l'a retiré sa mère enfin lui il peut
pas savoir les raisons pour lesquelles
on l'a fait puisqu'il avait deux ans
ils sont témoignage à lui c'est de dire
que sa mère avait un comportement cruel
à son égard on aurait pu éventuellement
des partager et découvrir la vérité si
le dossier de Frédéric était encore
disponible mais il a disparu
de sa mère à l'âge des exemples et que
c'est pas facile c'est sûr alors vous
partez avec votre grand-mère en Vendée
et là vous commencez à inventer des
histoires invraisemblables enfin
vraisemblable on sait rien mais par
exemple vous parlez d'un certain Michel
de 23 ans qui pratique des attouchements
sexuels sur vous un simple d'esprit
est-ce que c'est vrai ou est-ce que
c'est une affabulation Frédéric j'ai dit
la vérité vis-à-vis de la vérité
absolument c'était un pédophile il
aimait les jeunes garçons je n'ai jamais
vu avec un autre jeune garçon mais avec
ma propre expérience j'ai appris à
savoir qu'il aimait les jeunes les
jeunes garçons
[Musique]
voilà quoi alors à l'époque évidemment
vous êtes tellement malheureux que vous
vous venger de votre malheur sur vos
animaux vous faites souffrir les animaux
je torturer je jouais au football avec
mes cochons d'inde
à 12 ans vous êtes mis dans un foyer de
la banlieue de Nantes votre maire se bat
pas beaucoup pour vous garder il faut
dire les choses et là vous commencez
Frédéric à vous réfugier dans votre
monde imaginaire un monde où vous êtes
le seul maître à bord et finalement
cette façon de vivre dans ce monde
parallèle devient chez vous une
stratégie de survie c'est la c'est la
façon pour vous de continuer à pouvoir à
pouvoir exister
si vous êtes dans un monde et une
société
où tout le monde se fout de vous que
vous êtes seul que la seule fois où vous
avez raconté ce qui vous avez ce qui
vous est arrivé vous arrivez au nez on
vous a ignoré vous a traité de menteur
qu'on a pris les décisions qui étaient
supposées être les meilleurs pour vous
et qu'une fois adulte et on se retrouve
seul
c'est vrai que mon monde que j'avais
inventé à partir de l'âge de 12 ans et
ben il était vraiment très très pratique
un monde où j'étais aimé où j'étais
jamais seul voilà un monde de rêve en
quelque sorte alors que dans la vraie
vie dans ce foyer vous êtes victime
d'agression sexuelle pendant deux ans
alors ensuite pendant 7 ans vous allez
sillonner la France l'Europe ou de
fausses identités de foyers pour mineurs
en service psychiatrique espèce de de
fux sans fin comme ça c'est une espèce
de suicide mental une certaine façon je
sais très bien ce que je fais c'est très
bien que ce que je fais est en train de
me détruire petit peu à petit peu parce
que malheureusement quand j'aurai 15 ans
je pourrais plus me faire passer pour un
garçon de 15 ans
je sais malheureusement bien avant ça
c'est à dire je ne me donne plus
beaucoup de temps
je suis assez pessimiste c'est sûrement
futur mais assez réaliste parce que ce
n'est pas le fait de me décevoir et de
savoir je sais parfaitement ce que je
peux faire et ce que je ne peux pas
faire
et je sais très bien
que le futur pour les gens comme moi
enfin les gens qui sont en marche de la
société pas forcément comme moi
ne sont pas de c'est pas vraiment joli
ce qui leur arrive c'est quoi le spectre
c'est la rue tout ça pour échapper à la
rue aussi je ne serai jamais SDF je ne
serai jamais un clochard je ne dormirai
jamais dehors à part sous une tente je
ne m'en dirai jamais de l'argent passant
dans la rue je me tuerais si je devais
en arriver là
je n'ai pas peur de mourir j'ai peur de
vieillir j'ai peur de me retrouver seul
et de
et que tout le monde s'en foutent de
devoir faire des choses qui
donneraient raison aux gens qui qui me
jugent mal aux gens qui ne me
connaissent pas aux gens qui se disent
ce mec c'est un pervers peut-être qu'il
veut être avec les gamins pour les
tripoter ou peut-être que c'est s'il
fait ça pour le fric pour l'argent
toutes sortes de d'imagination stupides
et je veux pas donner des raisons à ces
gens là parce que je suis quelqu'un de
bien je suis pas quelqu'un de méchant je
suis quelqu'un qui veut simplement être
aimé c'est tout
jamais rencontré quelqu'un qui vous
tende la main et qui vous qui vous
prenne dans ses bras et qui vous aime
tout simplement
j'ai vu que j'ai vécu ça dans mon propre
monde
137 foyers il a fait dans 9 pays
différents pour vous c'est la seule
façon de pas sombrer dans la folie et en
fait vous recherchez les les foyers
parce que vous avez été privé d'enfance
donc c'est une façon de vous faire
materner effectivement préciser que ce
sont toujours des foyers de protection
pour une heure bien que ça m'arrive de
tomber dans des foyers délinquants je ne
vais jamais dans les foyers d'adultes et
là il se passe un truc absolument
incroyable pour la première fois vous
prenez l'identité d'un adolescent porté
disparu donc comme vous le ferez plus
tard avec le Léo balai dont je parlais
en commençant le garçon s'appelle
Nicolas alors il est blond il a les
tatouages donc jusque là ça va les
tatouages ça va blond c'est facile mais
il a les yeux bleus et vous vous avez
les yeux marrons et pour non non pas des
lentilles il a pas mis des lentilles il
a expliqué c'est là où il y a un grand
affabulateur il a expliqué qu'en fait il
avait les yeux bleus mais qu'il a été
kidnappé par des militaires américains
pédophiles qui lui ont fait non mais
c'est vrai j'y crois moi j'y
pour le transformer et ses yeux sont
devenus marrons ça arrive c'est
incroyable inimagination vous allez
jusqu'à rencontrer la famille de ce de
ce Nicolas alors là c'est très bizarre
parce qu'en fait on sait pas est-ce que
est-ce que la famille le reconnaît comme
le Fils et le frère est-ce que le
reconnaît pas est-ce qu'elle le
reconnaît parce qu'ils sont débarrassés
du vrai fils là c'est très trouble tout
ça vous me posez la question directement
vous moi je suis convaincu que la
famille n'a jamais cru une seconde qu'il
était Nicolas ouais ça c'est clair c'est
clair dès la première minute
la sœur de Nicolas qui vient chercher
Frédéric en Espagne c'est qu'il n'est
pas son frère les raisons pour
lesquelles
elle prend le risque parce que tu as un
risque qu'elle prend de lui faire faire
un passeport au nom de son frère et de
le ramener avec elle aux États-Unis
là on entre dans un roman policier on va
dire un roman policier
ce qui est très frappant et ce qui je
veux dire je mets au défi quiconque voit
les images de l'arrivée de Frédéric
Bourdin à l'aéroport de San Antonio
accueilli par sa mère je mets au défi
qui compte de ne pas voir que c'est une
une mauvaise mise en scène Frédéric
arrive le visage couvert avec une
écharpe une casquette enfoncée sur les
yeux et la mère qui n'avait pas vu son
fils depuis quatre ans qu'il le croyait
peut-être sans doute mort depuis 4 ans
elle se dirige maladroitement vers lui
elle le prend dans ses bras une demi
seconde et ensuite elle tourne le dos
elle s'en va voilà alors pourquoi
ont-ils fait semblant de croire que
c'était leur fils à ce moment-là
parce que la propre famille de Nicolas
l'assassiné
finalement ça les laver de tout soupçon
mais c'était assassinat n'a jamais été
prouvé non il n'a jamais été prouvé
c'était pas convenu on aurait pas donné
six ans de prison si jamais ça avait été
trouvé oui alors vous prenez 6 ans de
prison à cause de ça et là vous vous
glissez en prison dans la peau d'un
mexicain parce que les Mexicains dans
cette prison c'était vraiment les
c'était vraiment les taulier donc vous
devenez plus mexicain que les Mexicains
évidemment grâce à votre capacité de
caméléon quel est le titre du livre et
là alors vous faites même tatouer
Oussama Ben Laden en arabe sur le torse
parce que ça vous donnait une valeur par
rapport à tous ces gens-là qu'évidemment
détestent des tests l'Amérique et les
Américains c'est pas non plus pour me
donner une valeur mais dans le sens que
je déteste les Américains il est clair
c'est pas les Américains en particulier
je veux dire c'est pas Monsieur et
Madame Wilson que je déteste c'est le
gouvernement donc vous restez six ans en
prison quand même j'étais condamné à 5
ans et 11 mois de prison et j'ai fait
cinq ans et 8 mois si je me trompe
alors après vous revenez en France mais
vous n'arrivez pas à vivre comme tout le
monde
vous regrettez même un peu le calme de
la prison finalement vous aimez bien
quand on vous organise un petit peu
votre votre vie non je veux dire la
prise américaine me manquait pas
particulièrement c'est vrai que en
revenant en France j'ai été gracié à
Nice d'une peine antérieure parce qu'ils
avaient vu que j'avais déjà fait 6 ans
de prison aux États-Unis et mon premier
instinct ça a été de voilà je me dis bon
ben puisque tout le monde dit que je
fonctionne pas normalement et puisque
tout le monde a une maison un boulot et
des enfants une famille et ben je vais
essayer de commencer à faire la même
chose et donc j'ai été voir de la
famille à Auch des cousins des cousines
que j'adore avec leur maman que j'adore
aussi je suis arrivé là-bas ils m'ont
aidé on a refait mes papiers on a
les choses ont été très tolérants avec
moi j'adorais jouer à la PS2 et voilà
on a trouvé j'ai trouvé un travail
ils m'ont aidé aussi à trouver un petit
appartement voilà sauf que j'ai tenu en
tout pour le tout je suis arrivé là-bas
au mois d'octobre et je suis reparti au
mois de décembre parce que
une fois que j'étais dans ce petit
appartement il y avait rien rien du tout
j'étais
comme avant tout seul je n'ai jamais eu
aucune idée de comment me fermer de
comment me faire des amis
à part
en changeant l'identité le soir vous
retrouviez seul dans chez vous quoi
ça me fait bizarre de dire chez moi
parce que je considérais pas ça chez moi
c'est là que vous inventez l'histoire de
Léo balai dont on a parlé tout à l'heure
en fait vous êtes seul dans une espèce
de prison mentale que vous vous êtes
construit à partir de vos souffrances
d'enfance et ce qui ressort de la
lecture du livre en tous les cas hein je
ne veux pas me vanter de souffrir plus
que les autres mais ma souffrance à moi
c'est intolérable elle est permanente
cette souffrance la plupart des gens
vivent et par moments survivent moi je
survis tout le temps et par moment je
vis par moment je me sens bien par
moment je me sens bien mais la majorité
du temps et bien je suis trop occupé à
me changer et à me préparer pour essayer
de me sentir bien et c'est pas une vie
je comprends alors est-ce que vous êtes
prêt à vous adapter à la réalité ou vous
allez continuer dans cette voie est-ce
que vous êtes prêt à faire des efforts
ou au contraire vous dites c'est fini je
vais je vais toute ma vie vivre comme ça
et bien le Frédéric Bourdin réaliste
pourrait vous répondre
j'ai jamais réussi il y a aucune raison
que j'ai réussi maintenant mon plus
grand souhait à moi c'est
de réussir à changer de vie
de réussir à me transformer une fois une
fois pour toute
mais c'est un rêve je veux dire il y a
des gens qui rêvent de tas de choses de
gagner au loto moi ce rêve là c'est pas
plus réel que pour les gens qui disent
je vais gagner au loto c'est je sais pas
comment je n'ai aucune idée comme un et
comme je suis pas malade d'après les
psychiatres et les psychologues et
moi j'en ai lu j'en ai entendu des tas
de gens et des tas de choses
et ben si personne ne me comprend alors
que c'est l'inverse c'est moi qui ne
comprends personne
qu'est-ce qui peut m'aider qu'est-ce qui
peut me faire changer qu'est-ce je sais
pas je sais pas quoi faire je suis très
croyant mais je ne m'attache à aucune
religion je ne suis pas catholique je ne
suis pas protestant je ne suis pas
musulman je crois en Dieu c'est tout
vous avez déjà été amoureux oui ça n'a
pas ça n'a pas aidé ben c'est très
compliqué à partir du moment où je
connaîtrais une fille de lui dire bon
ben voilà je m'appelle Frédéric Bourdin
et j'étais dans 137 foyers différents
dans tous les pays d'Europe et les
femmes peuvent avoir beaucoup de
compassion mais le problème avec les
gens comme moi c'est que il y a cette
mentalité comme vous dites on appelle un
menteur professionnel alors que moi ce
que je défends c'est que la seule chose
que j'ai toujours menthe sur lesquelles
j'ai toujours menti c'est mon identité
et mon âge je n'ai jamais menti
vis-à-vis de mes sentiments je ne suis
pas capable de faire ça parce que je me
connais donc j'ai peur j'ai peur d'abord
je vous répète je ne suis pas bon à me
faire des amis parce que je suis trop
timide et en deuxièmement je
j'ai trop peur que à partir du moment où
la personne se rend compte qu'elle a
affaire à quelqu'un qui est quand même
un petit peu connu maintenant
qu'elle pense que je suis le grand
manipulateur qui va bouger l'esprit qui
va vouloir lui faire faire ce que je
veux faire face et c'est pas c'est pas
moi dis-toi il y a un risque quand même
avec tout ça c'est clair vous vous
maîtrisez là ça va vous êtes mais
peut-être qu'un jour vous allez moins
bien arriver à maîtriser devenir fou
être un de ces messieurs qu'on voit dans
la rue je parlais tout seul
je crains énormément ça
je crains énormément ça et là vous êtes
borderline comment on dit en anglais
quoi ça j'en suis pas encore là je suis
encore capable je crois de me rendre
compte de la réalité des choses et il
est vrai que si je me voyais sombrer
comme je vous dis
je préférerais le suicider et qu'est-ce
qu'on peut faire pour t'aider
vous avez un chéquier non je plaisante
parce que j'ai fait du cinéma mais j'en
ai un
[Musique]
non mais tu cherches pas du boulot tu
veux pas lancer un appel le seul appel
que je voudrais lancer éventuellement
c'est mes excuses à toute personne que
j'ai jamais offensé à qui j'ai fait du
mal c'est ça parce que ça n'a jamais été
mon intention
maintenant ce qu'on peut faire pour
m'aider
mais prier pour moi c'est tout
il y a une chose il y a une chose que tu
pourrais faire en tous les cas c'est
acteur parce que le boulot d'un acteur
c'est j'adore
ça mais malheureusement faut connaître
du monde
je ne veux pas je ne pense que Dominique
bessenard regarde l'émission Ça peut
l'intérêt
en tous les cas merci d'être venu
témoigner aussi sincèrement merci
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
Inna larditude abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu